Oui, il me laissait des messages
planqués dans les briques à l'arrière de la boutique caritative
pour qu'on se retrouve.
Et il me racontait qu'il allait quitter sa femme,
et moi je le croyais, jusqu'à ce que je tombe enceinte.
Et là, Peter, je lui ai laissé un message dans notre endroit spécial là-bas,
et je n'ai plus jamais entendu parler de lui.
Non, je l'ai fait adopter pour qu'il ait une vie convenable.
Après ça, ils ne voulaient plus que je retourne au couvent.
Non, mon unique sœur Virginia m'a donné 5 livres pour le bus vers Dublin,
et c'est comme ça que je me suis retrouvée ici.
Et, surprise, je suis tombée amoureuse d'un autre gars bien plus âgé que moi,
et comme je dis toujours, j'étais si heureuse qu'il ne boive pas,
que j'ai épousé ce salaud.
Alors, il ne buvait pas, mais il avait un problème avec l’'héroine, tu vois,
et -- C'est juste, et avant de m'en rendre compte,
il a été celui qui m'a amenée vers la prostitution, mon propre mari.
Il m'a fait subvenir à nos besoins.
J'avais 18 ans.
Et, c'était pas Pretty Woman, je peux te le dire.
Cette Julia Roberts,
si elle avait dû coucher avec un homme pour avoir quelques livres en poche,
je pense pas qu'elle aurait fait ce film.
Et, pour ton information,
mon opinion sur la légalisation, je dirais que je suis contre.
Ça m'est égal ce que ces jeunes filles disent.
Tu sais, quand tu vis comme ça, t'es juste paumée,
et, tu vois, j'ai 63 ans.
J'essaye encore de trouver qui je suis.
Tu sais, j'ai jamais été une épouse ou une nonne,
ou même une prostituée, pas vraiment.
Personne ne m'a jamais demandé qui je veux être.
Ils m'ont juste ordonné,
et si on légalise ça,
alors on dit vraiment à ces filles : « Vas-y, vends ton âme pour vivre. »
et beaucoup d'entre elles, elles font ce qu'on leur dit.
Bien, donc quatre perspectives venant de quatre -- (Applaudissements) --
de quatre voix assez différentes, non ?
Une femme qui dit que le sexe est naturel mais que l'industrie du sexe paraît
le mécaniser ou l'industrialiser.
Puis la seconde femme qui considère que le travail du sexe est valorisant,
libérateur, et féministe, même si elle n'avait pas l'air
motivée pour le faire personnellement.
La troisième femme, qui était vraiment une travailleuse du sexe
ne trouvait pas ça libérateur mais elle voulait avoir accès
à l'émancipation économique,
et enfin on a entendu la quatrième femme qui disait que la prostitution
mais aussi les rôles imposés aux femmes en général
l'avaient empêchée de découvrir qui elle était, vous voyez ?
Sinon, un truc que beaucoup de gens ne savaient pas,
c'était que l'âge moyen auquel une fille à risque
était exposée à l'industrie du sexe était 12 ou 13 ans.
Donc on considère que l'âge auquel toutes les filles de la société
étaient exposées pour la première fois à des images sexualisées des femmes
était un peu plus jeune, d'accord ?
Ceci était une poupée nommée Barbie, OK ?
Au début j'ai cru que c'était un outil pédagogique contre l'anorexie --
(Rires) --
mais elle était en fait considérée par beaucoup
comme un symbole sain de féminité,
et souvent les jeunes filles commençaient ce qui s'appelait un régime --
Vous vous souvenez ? C'était le fait de limiter sa nourriture intentionnellement.
-- à l'âge de 6 ans,
et elles se définissaient par des critères d'attractivité
environ au même âge. D'accord ?
Oui ?
Bien, Bradley, oui, très bon point.
Il y avait donc un marché lucratif dans la société pour convaincre les gens
qu'ils devaient avoir un certain physique pour avoir une vie sexuelle, d'accord ?
Mais les filles, en particulier, devaient être « sexy » tout en évitant
d'être vues comme des « salopes » car elles étaient sexuelles. D'accord ?
C'est la partie honte dont on a déjà parlé.
Oui.
Valérie, oui ? D'accord, très bien.
Bien sûr, les hommes avaient du sexe aussi,
mais vous vous rappelez de la leçon,
comment on appelait les salopes mâles ?
Très bien, on les appelait des hommes.
(Rires) (Applaudissements)
Donc ce n'était pas facile de vivre dans un monde comme ça, d'accord?
Mais, il n'y avait pas que des mauvaises nouvelles.
Beaucoup de femmes des années 2000 se considéraient émancipées,
et les hommes se sentaient en général également évolués dans ce domaine,
en fait, la majorité des gens étaient conscients des problèmes
tels que la traite des personnes,
mais ils voyaient ça comme étant séparé
des divertissements pour adultes plus récréatifs.
Et donc nous allons juste brièvement -- nous n'avons pas beaucoup de temps --
nous allons juste brièvement écouter un homme
parler de notre sujet à ce stade.
Donc le prochain a été interrogé la nuit de son enterrement de vie de garçon.
Mec, tu peux, OK, tu peux juste baisser un peu ?
J'essaye de parler à BERT là.
Oh, ton nom c'est pas BERT.
BERT c'est le nom du, oh, d'accord.
Non, non, parfait, tout va bien. je suis presque sobre,
donc je veux juste aider.
Ouais, je suis à fond dans les causes, ouais ce style de trucs.
(Rires)
Et en fait je porte des Toms là.
Ouais, Toms, les chaussures,
style, tu achètes une paire et ensuite un gamin en Afrique a de l'eau potable.
Ouais. À fond.
Mais c'était quoi la question déjà ? Désolé.
Sûr, je suis pour les droits des femmes. Je me marie avec une femme.
(Rires)
Non mais, juste parce que je suis sur le parking d'un club de strip tease,
ça veut pas dire que je suis, genre, un macho ou un truc du genre.
Ma fiancée est juste incroyable, c'est une fille forte, une femme forte,
intelligente et tout.
Ouais, elle sait que je suis là. Elle est probablement dans un club de strip aussi,
mais pour blaguer, comme moi.
Mon témoin, je lui ai dit de me faire une surprise,
et il a pensé que ça serait drôle,
mais c'est pas important.
Ouais, on a tous fait l'école de commerce ensemble.
Wharton.
(Rires)
Ouais, mec, les mecs vous pouvez --
D'accord, mais c'est ma soirée,
et je peux la passer sur le parking avec Anderson Cooper si je veux.
OK, je vous rejoins à l'intérieur.
D'accord, bon Anderson,
donc, déjà, faire du strip tease,
mais après, tous les autres trucs dont tu parles,
la prostitution, ce genre de choses, c'est, genre, pas du tout la même chose.
Genre, t'arrêtes pas d'appeler ça l'industrie du sexe ou quoi,
mais si la fille veut être une danseuse exotique
et elle a 18 ans, c'est son droit.
Holà, j'entends ce que tu dis, mais j'ai l'impression que les gens,
ils veulent juste donner l'impression que tous les mecs sont des prédateurs,
qu'on va tous automatiquement aller voir une prostituée ou quoi.
Même quand j'ai juré, tu sais, genre, quand je suis entré dans ma fraternité,
mes frères dont je suis proche, ces mecs, ils sont tous comme moi.
On est juste des mecs normaux, mais il y a ce mythe que tu dois
être ce mec qui est une espèce de salaud, genre, les potes avant les meufs et tout.
Et en fait, les potes avant les meufs, c'est pas ce que les gens croient.
C'est juste une façon marrante de dire que les potes sont plus importants
que tout le reste pour toi.
Ouais, mais, tu peux pas en vouloir aux médias non plus.
Je veux dire, si tu vas voir « Very bad trip 2 »,
et que tu penses que c'est un guide
pour ta vie, genre, je sais pas quoi te dire.
Tu vois ? Tu vas pas voir « la Mémoire dans la peau »
et ensuite conduire sur une gondole à Venise. (Rires)
Bon, ouais, OK, si t'es un gosse ou quoi,
bien sûr c'est différent, mais --
Ouais, OK, je me rappelle d'un truc comme ça.
J'étais chez un autre gamin une fois pour jouer à GTA,
euh, Grand Theft Auto ?
Mec, t'es du Canada ou quoi ? (Rires)
Ouais, bref, avec Grand Theft Auto,
t'es ce gosse, enfin, tu es ce gars, tu te balades et tout,
et en gros tu peux, genre, plus tu tues de flics,
plus tu gagnes de points, ce style de trucs.
Mais aussi, tu peux trouver des prostituées
et bien sûr tu peux faire des trucs sexuels avec elles,
mais tu peux aussi les tuer et récupérer ton argent.
Ouais, ce gosse, il en a écrasé quelques-unes avec sa voiture
et il gagnait plein de points.
On avait 10 ans, je pense.
J'étais mal à l'aise, en fait.
Non, je crois que j'ai rien dit, j'ai fini de jouer et je suis rentré.
D'accord jeunes gens, il y avait aussi des hommes qui avaient un lien
plus fort avec ce sujet. (Rires)
Le prochain sujet se décrit comme étant un ancien souteneur repenti
qui est devenu un conférencier de motivation,
un coach de vie et un thérapeute,
mais si vous voulez en savoir plus, vous devez venir à la pièce complète.
Merci beaucoup, vous êtes un public TED formidable.
Je vous verrai pour « vendre/acheter/sortir ».
(Applaudissements)